to every story was interviewed by Brian
Williams for them NBC Nightly News and
he later couple bombs I mean huge
breaking news we've got to quit so
realistic livers
I was trained as a spy and sort of the
traditional sense of the word in that I
we have to work
undercover overseas pretending to work
in a job that I'm not
I and even being assigned a name that
was not mine
I'm but I am
a technical specialists I'm a technical
exper
I don't work with people I don't break
room
agents what I do is I put systems to
work
for the United States I and I've done at
all levels
from from the bottom on the ground all
the way to the top I
okay that seems pretty huge nobody knew
about this even President Obama saying
he was a low-level
systems analyst or a low-level hacker
everyone in the government
has been saying that whereas you can
hear more about this but
this is human trait I don't know I don't
know that it's huge it's
interesting and the debate about who
eric's
ago Eric snow that is that the picnic
well yesterday
Edward Edward she's I like when I i
money yet
a debate about Edwards snowden
interesting
like and I like talking about it but
it's not really important
like it still only matters what you
really
still only matters what he released
and and you know at and what we're gonna
do about it
like to end the debate that comes
afterwards like import the
administration tries to minimize it but
doesn't really
it doesn't really surprise me you know
and it does it
again expose it we find out that that he
should have been their argument could
quickly change
quickly shift from he's not high enough
ranking
to know better to now they could go he
should have known better
yeah but you know so I mean I'll at that
that's why I don't
it interesting it's it's great we
interesting that are either really
changes with the most important
discussions about this RB yeah with what
you said that he dropped to
big bombs like dogs eat a lot
Salvadorian food but the
that wasn't the case and I like it with
Brian Williams give us a serious face
with a retired
but then he had to take it into a
follow-up is it a copy at an improv
class over the UC be
he had to get to right away people are
commonly yeah what we talked about
snowed in yet all this by are you
surprised a
yes I because we've been to again what
what what we've been told is that this
guy's a low-level human
than and I always said we'll a piece on
the low block me as access all this
unbelievable information it turns out
that these are bringing spy
and you said but doesn't that make Obama
look bad
writes a book which I was saying well
then how did they let Obama keep going
out there and keep saying he's a low
level because that's what they do they
discredit
so whoever is bomb blows the gives out
information
that they don't want to give out they
discredit him just like they did with
Valerie Plame and her husband
when he discredited FAA so it's just the
conspiracies happen right out in the
open and then when someone says hey this
is a good thing that's happening
they discredit him and that's exactly
what he saying that they've been doing
so you think Obama new and then yes you
think someone I see anat wait until we
get some
look there's gonna the that cover we're
gonna the United States gonna say
something
different about what is level spying was
why I my hunch is that there is probably
away
you can had his if you to believe is a
low level position
you actually described look is a low
level position who
if it is a low level position who
installed systems
for the National Security Administration
to keep our secret safe like
it's not like a low-level rally at the
Young Turks I mean I could so
but he was a janitor this great little
stuff was still pretty
right so even like my there may not even
be a different
in in our gym what he did it just
characterizing it like
the NSA might say with they were is
thirty-seven people to report to you
before he got to the other the NSA an
ego I was essentially spy
that's why like II RTC at conversation
devolving nationally about this that
then I wouldn't be that interested
like I'm interested in his politics and
what motivated him in
is he gonna get prosecuted like that
stuff interest me again
another that is as important as a that
what you released
and how we react to that as a country
director as you're both saying of course
the government is going to look to
discredit him and he addressed that now
the camera
mind the 90s think they might freemen in
certain ways and say all you know he's a
low-level analyst
but what they're trying to do is they're
trying to use
one position that iPad and a career here
were there
to distract from the totality of my
experience which is that
I've worked for the central intelligence
agency undercover
overseas I've worked for the National
Security Agency
undercover overseas and I'm work for the
defense
intelligence agency has a lecture at the
joint counterintelligence training
academy
where I developed sources and methods
for keeping our information people
secure
in the most hardstyle dangerous
environments around the world
so when they say I'm a little Systems
Administrator that I don't know what I'm
talking about
I'd say it's somewhat misleading I'm
obviously very pro snowden improve the
release of the second period thing
slightly cryptic about him right maybe
that just comes with the job you know
I was watching the see where we watched
it together CNN's
take on that they ran that play out in
the CNN anchor I can identify
body could play anchorman on virtually
any television girl very professional
very professional afterwards he said
quote a lot of energy is put me into
giving a sense of importance to its
position
CNN will take a stand on climate change
I
writing me they can literally bring
someone on the network who will deny a
that evolution
exists but they'll think shot it snowed
in at the first opportunity
but so I think you will that see a lot
of that
that said he was really into giving
themselves as report
that but if you were being minimized by
other people your natural
any persons that a response would be to
say normal you're right
eurozone right we can't get too caught
up in the the new ones every little
thing he says and how he says it cuz
that's not what this is really about
yet so I think that if your CNN
going back to your point if you're going
to try and discredit Edward snowed in
you have to do with backs like oh yeah
he said he was a spy turns out he was
right
turns out he said he said he worked
overseas doing this he did it you can
just go
while he's putting a lot a review the
dry and wet bag is important well they
say what he said was with Paul scored a
quiet
it was true everything he said he was
well that's what bullshit about
that CNN what about the other thing was
total bullshit it was a weird better
editorializing and there's only one
response to this is you call
the DIA in the CIA and the NSA you say
what was a job and they go
we're not telling you and then you say
by the way we call these people to see
there still was telling the truth
and they wouldn't comment right so I'm
looking at actual good story I'm gonna
get CNN will be there but somebody might
do that to my final thought is
you think these guys ever stepping foot
in the US again no
is there any chance that Lena maybe
jimmy carter's president again
I guess that put the UI I look I'm gonna
just said II there's a scenario where he
sets with the US
and he spends a little bit I'm in jail
on
that worked out and that's what I do
that's how I'd handle I put him in jail
I they've been consistent in that I
wouldn't put in that would travel well
is that he got a traitor you're right
but but you know some other things he
gave up
were things that he should be given up
because he gave up so much tougher
turned out there was some stuff in the
probably shoulda got
the essay stuff is incredibly important
that we all know like it but the guy in
jail for three years tweeted
write down every bit a federally by he
brought a book you get
gazillionaire after right however
everybody wins sometimes we just deal
with it yourself you know about the way
to Afghanistan the other day and we
accidentally outed wanna borrow inspired
by putting them on a list the people
there and show up in Obama's event so we
do it
whether snowed in doing this or nitro by
the way goes on Fox News and compares it
to Valerie Plame's is worth about
pleaded
intentionally and then lies about
director better that's a whole other
story there